The fourth final exam question is another creative application as in concepts you've learned.
We're going to deal with a three-body problem.
Let's say that we've three stars--one with a small mass, one with the twice the smallest star's mass,
and one very large star with three times this mass.
Given the certain initial 3D configuration of these stars, we want you to figure out
how to position and graph each change of time.
One piece of information that's going to be very important is this equation as the gravitational force
between two bodies, which you should remember from all the new units.
Tremendous that this force is actually vector quantity.
I'm going to be super explicit in putting a vector sign on top of that.
Remember, all three of these bodies exert a force one way or another.
In the code you can see that we've written out the mass at each star for you
as well as the gravitational constant big G.
We've dealt with everything concerning time for you and all left for you to do
is to implement this symplectic Euler method for the motion of the stars we did write above.
When that is symplectic Euler method if the kind of half implicit, half explicit method
that'll help you find the position and velocity of each star.
Just show your result and surprise you. This is a chaotic system.
See it showed a pretty interesting looking graph.